Hi, I'm Chet Haase,
an engineer on the
Android team at Google.
I work on graphics
and animation.
Today I want to just talk about
a way of using a class
called View Property Animator,
which was introduced in the
3.2 release.
And this is a way to animate
properties of views
in a very easy way.
It's kind of like setting the
value of one of the properties
on the view but having it
animate to that value instead
of just atomically
switch to it.
So there's much more I could
go into about View Property
Animator in general.
What we're going to see today is
an effect where we can use
View Property Animator to cross
fade between different
images in a picture viewer.
So let's take a look
at the demo.
So we saw another demo in a
previous episode where we used
transition Drawable to
do something similar.
Although that particular
Drawable animation is about
switching just between
two images.
This one's a little bit more
general purpose, where we have
a set of images in here that
we've loaded and we're going
to cross fade as we
go between them.
And we'll just keep
going through the
entire set of images.
A little bit more
general purpose.
So as we click on the image we
get a nice fading effect as we
go to the next image and
on and on and then
we just cycle around.
I only have four images
loaded in here for the
purposes of this demo.
So, pretty pictures.
Not a terribly interesting
demo.
But let's take a look
at the code.
So we have this class called
Picture Viewer and in it--
I'm just hard coding these.
I'm just loading in these
small images that I had.
Not the way to go for a general
picture viewing
application, obviously.
But it does for this purpose,
which is to demonstrate using
View Property Animator
and cross fading
between these things.
So we have two image views
that we're going to fade
between, where we're going
to put these resources.
And we're going to first of all
set up the View Property
Animator on these views to
have a duration of 1,000.
One thing to be aware of with
View Property Animator is the
way that you use it is by
calling view.animate and that
returns you a reference to the
View Property Animator which
all views have.
So they only have that one
instance inside them, although
it's unique to that view.
So if you want to change the
[INAUDIBLE] properties on a
View Property Animator, such as
the duration, then you call
.animate and then
call the setter.
In this case we're setting
the duration to be 1,000.
I should point out that
is too long for a
general purpose UI animation.
But for the purposes of actually
demonstrating this
today, in this video I tend to
use longer durations so you
can actually see the animation
depending on the
frame rate of the video.
Then we create bit map Drawables
from these hard
coded images, these Drawables
that I defined above.
Nothing very interesting
going on there.
And then for the previous and
the next image view we
populate them with the first
and second Drawable there.
And then when we click-- this
is where all the interesting
stuff happened--
we basically performed two
animations in parallel.
We're going to animate the
existing image that everybody
can see out and we're going to
animate and we're going to
fade the new image, the
next image, in.
And then when it's done we're
going to restore some values
and then we're going to set up
the references to which images
we're currently showing so
that we can keep cycling
through the set of images
that we have.
So here we're going to animate
the alpha property, which is
the translucency property
of the previous image.
It is currently 1 because that's
the image that the user
is currently seeing.
And we're going to animate it
by saying animate, which
returns as View Property
Animator object .alpha 0.
So this is basically saying,
I want you to animate.
I want to set the alpha property
to 0, but I want you
to animate it there over
whatever your duration is.
And we're going to call
withLayer and I'll explain
that in a moment.
This is sort of an important
element to understand for
performance tuning.
And then Next Image View,
instead of fading that out
like the previous one, we're
going to fade it in.
So as the old one fades
out we're going to
fade the new one in.
So you can think of them as sort
of sitting on top of one
another and we're going to cross
fade them by fading one
out and fading the other one
in all at the same time.
And then there's a new
API that was added.
I believe this is in Jelly
Bean and it's called
withEndAction.
And you can mimic this in
prior releases simply by
setting a listener on a View
Property Animator and doing
the same exact thing.
This is just a little bit more
terse way of doing that.
You can say when this animation
is done, then I want
you to perform the following
actions.
We're going to update our
references so that we know
which images we're actually
looking at right now, and then
we're going to restore some
alpha properties.
So we're going to set the alpha
property of 1 to 0 and
set the other alpha property to
1 so that they're at a good
state to animate from for the
next transition that we do.
Now I want to get back to
this withLayer thing.
This is important.
When you're animating a complex
view or complex view
hierarchy, it's important to
use a layer on that object,
especially if you've noticed a
frame rate problem because the
system can't keep up with
redrawing that thing from
scratch every time during
the animation.
An easy way to do that
is to set a layer
type on that object.
So you simply call
view.setLayerType and set it
to a hardware layer,
for example.
And this API that we have here
as of Jelly Bean the withLayer
API is a way for us to
do that for you.
So you could do that when
you run the animation.
You could say set layer type on
the View and then you could
put some more code in here with
your end action, or you
could set a listener for the end
of the animation and then
reset that layer or
remove that layer.
But we'll do that automatically
for you if you
call the withLayer method.
So today's episode was about
View Property Animator and
specifically using View Property
Animator to get a
very easy cross fade operation
between different
representations of views.
Thanks.